buen dia raúl te saludo desde
tegucigalpa no solo por el hecho de que
ya sea maracas por la ventaja en unos 20
puntos a su contendiente nasry asfura
sino porque el mismo oscura y estas
algunas imágenes esperadas por el pueblo
de honduras
divulgó fotografías en la que
evidentemente se encuentra en la
residencia de xiomara castro y
posteriormente escuchamos el discurso
que pronunció felicitando y reconociendo
que es la nueva presidenta de honduras y
abro comillas con lo que digo asegura
nosotros respetamos la voluntad del
pueblo
expresado en las urnas porque es la
decisión de las mayorías dijo asegura en
una acción que está haciendo muy muy
aplaudida por el pueblo hondureño que
estos días posteriores a las elecciones
pues ha despertado con cierta
tranquilidad y eran precisamente lo que
no sucedió al ir y al concluir el
proceso electoral anterior en donde
ninguno de los candidatos reconocía la
derrota se alargó el proceso y esto por
supuesto probó con los hechos violentos
que provocaron más de 30 muertos en el
país situación que ya honduras no estaba
dispuesta a vivir y por eso salió
masivamente a votar en estas elecciones
generales ahora kenia con lo que se
conoce hasta ahora le pregunto cómo va
la conformación del nuevo parlamento
hondureño
eso es muy importante raúl porque para
que se llamará castro cumpla algunas de
las promesas que por ejemplo para
acabamos de escuchar que va a terminar
con la corrupción en el país necesita
esta mayoría en el congreso nacional lo
que hasta el momento están logrando no
sólo por si sola con su partido libertad
y refundación sino que se están sumando
los diputados que también está
alcanzando en este momento su designado
presidencial y el otro que se le unió a
esta comisión salvador narrará así que y
continúan este conteo favorable para
ellas para castró tendrá mayoría en el
congreso nacional y por supuesto una de
las primeras reformas que se espera de
ella es justamente terminar con las
últimas reformas dicho sea de paso que
se dieron al código procesal penal que
para muchos en honduras representa un
pelo de impunidad para los corruptos